Milton Friedman famously said you cannot simultaneously have free immigration
and a welfare state. Economist Brian Caplan begs to differ.
Caplan makes his case in his latest book,
"Open Borders The Science and Ethics of Immigration."
It's a graphic novel he co-produced with artist Zach Weinersmith,
who's best known as the creator of the popular web comic, "Saturday Morning Breakfast Cereal."
The book takes on all the arguments against open borders one by one. From concerns about assimilation,
terrorism, and fairness, to Friedman's oft-quoted libertarian objection. Caplan sat down with us
to talk about why immigration works, if he thinks he'll see open borders in his lifetime,
and why he likes to pick fights in his books.
Bryan Caplan you seem to love to pick
fights basically all of your books have
been insanely controversial topics this
one is no exception
open borders is generally considered a
radical idea
are you a radical yes I am but
especially I'm someone who figures that
if is a conventional idea someone else
write the book or the books already
written 20 times so I feel like my value
added is to find the orphan topics
topics where they have great merit
position has great merit but almost no
one else loves them and I like to adopt
them and say look I love you I will
raise you I will make you strong and
then I will unleash you on the world and
let the world see how much they should
have given you how much credit they
should have given you how how quickly
they were to dismiss you when actually
this was a great idea so yeah that's
really what I do with all my books is I
try to find ideas that otherwise
probably the book wouldn't be written at
all and then I write the book India for
me that's very motivating because it's
the thought of if I don't do this no one
will and that's why I picked the topics
I do have you always been in favor of
open borders or did you have a
conversion moment let's see so when I
was in high school I actually had to
write an essay on immigration for my
bioethics class and I was definitely not
in favor of open borders then I was
someone who basically said immigrations
good as far as it goes we need better
simulation so still when I actually
changed my mind probably it was actually
just reading libertarian authors and
saying this isn't a proper role for
government but what really radicalized
me was
the philosophy it was actually seeing
what research were saying about the
actual games of open borders because
there's so many different policy reforms
you could talk about but what really
counts what would make an enormous
difference in the quality of life for
large numbers of people one of the
biggest things in fact the biggest
results that you can get out of
empirical research is no one in
economics has ever come up with a better
policy reform than radical
liberalization of migration because
there's so much human talent that goes
to waste in countries where they aren't
able to accomplish much and they could
just move freely to another country
people could do so much more they could
lift themselves out of poverty by their
own bootstraps but the law doesn't allow
it
Soniya work by researchers like Michael
Clements he has this famous piece of
subtitle trillion dollar bills on the
sidewalk and that's what got me thinking
not only is this a good idea but it's an
incredibly important idea and since very
few people are pushing it I should be
someone that does it why a graphic novel
why would you make this sort of abstruse
academic argument in graphic novel form
so several reasons so one of them is
that a lot of the arguments that I make
about open borders involve thought
experiments and I found thought
experiments just work a lot better if
you can see them rather than just
picture them in the eye of the mind also
I notice from reading a lot of these
nonfiction graphic novels cuz I'm a
voracious reader of the stuff that's the
very best of them don't give a
simplistic low-level story instead the
very best of them combine words and
pictures just convey a lot of
information extremely economically and I
wanted to model myself after the greats
like Larry donek whose cartoon history
the universe and five volumes is a
fantastic work and I would just make it
the textbook for history across the
whole world if I were given that power
so I mean I just realized there was so
much opportunity to go and combine words
and pictures to convey a lot of
information very readily and in a short
amount of time and then you know finally
it was just something very different and
I thought it was really fun and you know
I've seen if I could do this wouldn't
this be a great experience for me now
there's a problem I can't draw which is
where Zach Weiner Smith comes in you
also added probably about one out of
five jokes
buddy and since he's also a professional
humorist as well as an artist a lot of
this role was to tell me my jokes did
not suck and so people say the books
funny of course authors gonna say that
but this is a funny book read it it's
true in the opening of the book you do
have a sort of historical section where
you look back at the history of
immigration of restriction in this
country and you say one reason we know
that open borders can work is because we
had them essentially until really the
20s yeah that argument I have attempted
to make in similar conversations I find
that you get the instant response but
things are different now so Brian aren't
things different now oh so they are as
to whether that makes immigration better
or worse as a very interesting question
I deal with this later in the book so me
on the question of assimilation many
people have rightly said well now it's a
lot easier to move to a country and then
use modern communications and
transportation to not really adapt new
country and that's true as far as it
goes
however modern communication and
transportation have also already moved
Western and especially American culture
outwards to the rest of the world so you
can see things like now there's about a
billion people who don't live in
countries that are officially
english-speaking and yet speak fluent
English in 1900 it would not have been
so in 1900 a Sicilian migrants is not
just going to show up a bellows island
speaking probably no English never
having seen electricity maybe and now
you'd be hard-pressed to find anyone in
the whole country of Italy that is so
out of touch with modern culture so what
I call this pre assimilation I say that
we have in the modern rose a lot more
pre assimilation where immigrants are
already not only linguistically but
culturally and economically adapted to
life in more advanced countries so they
really can hit the ground running
you know I'll also say it's new it's
there's a big difference Mena policy
that's never been done and a policy it
was very successful for a very long time
and then stopped and especially why I
think the history does matter is that
it's very hard to find anyone including
the most ardent immigration restriction
s who think that it was a good idea to
stop the immigration in the way that it
was done almost everyone looking back
will say all right the complaints they
had then were off base and if the
complaints are so similar to the
complaints now and they made sense to
people the time which really should make
you wonder
could there be some built-in human bias
towards xenophobia and pessimism that
leaves human beings to overrate the
dangers of immigration such that when
you will have some distance in
perspective you see how silly that the
complaints are but when you are caught
up in the moment you have trouble
accepting that maybe you could be wrong
you said earlier that it was reading
various libertarian thinkers that kind
of brought you into the open borders
mindset but there are certainly a plenty
of libertarians self-described
libertarians who don't favor open
borders you address some of those
arguments in your book there they're
literal they're not straw men I guess
they're stick men but they're little
they're little stick figures in taxation
is theft t-shirts who are clamoring
across your lawn given our expected
viewership here at Reason TV could you
talk a little bit about those arguments
and your replies to them
sure so there's two sets of arguments
that we can think about here that
libertarians have made so the kind of
argument that I think are terrible and
fairly clearly so are the ones saying
look well just as I can exclude people
from my house American can slewed people
from the country because this is our
collective property and it might apply
to people like this is that's what you
think you really shouldn't be a
libertarian because if that's what you
think then you have no principled
objection anything government does
people are not allowed to set up a
church inside my house therefore
government should be able to decide what
religions are able to be practiced here
you can't set up a store or an export
import firm inside of my house the air
force should be the people the united
states that decide which businesses to
license attend which for which countries
we get to trade with and so on so if you
really think that the country
collectively Bron belongs to the
citizens and we the people of the right
to do with this country what we want
then you have abandoned any kind of a
principled libertarian argument
certainly you don't have a right to have
a gun in my house right so who why
should he be able to have a gun in
America if America doesn't think that
you should show me a that's a kind of
argument that is popular with people who
like principled philosophical arguments
although you know it's just such a
terrible argument and one where the
people are making it on such an ad-hoc
basis where it's only for that purpose
they ever make the arguments they would
never allow government to do anything
else by the same logic
now the libertarian arguments that I
think are vastly better and I try to
address them with great seriousness
are especially one saying first of all
that due to the welfare state we can't
afford to let immigrants in because it
would break the bank right so there's
that one in Milton Friedman as many
libertarians have keep emailing me as if
I'd never heard of it but yes so have
you heard it yes guys it's Milton
Friedman in the book this tells me the
quote that I have heard from any other
vegetarians saying essentially you
cannot have free migration and a welfare
state right so I have a chapter right
just go over the numbers say well it
depends it's complicated you can't do
this kind of math in your head you've
got to actually do this the slow
painstaking boring work of crunching the
numbers or at least reading the slow
boring painstaking work that other
people have done and in that chapter I
come away saying look we can imagine a
welfare state so generous that it would
break the bank but the u.s. is not such
a welfare state for a bunch of reasons
which I'm happy to go into then and then
you know the argument that I take it as
much more serious is maybe the
immigrants are gonna come from countries
where they love liberty even less than
Americans do and we're going to vote to
turn us in to Venezuela or something
like that so yeah this is an argument
where I understand the logic of it but
it comes down to an empirical question
is it really true that's non-native
people in this country or that bad if we
go and look at subgroups or we try to
figure out how would the composition of
immigrants change if anyone who wanted
to could come how bad would that be me
and so I mean I just go through the data
there and I just say look this there may
be some small effect but it is no one
even in the right ballpark to justify
this extreme violation of human freedom
which is what immigration restrictions
really are this is not like saying that
you're not allowed to go and have a
bonfire in your backyard or something
like that
this is something where you are taking
billions of people who would like to
move from desperate poverty to the first
world to get a job and rent an apartment
to capitalist acts of seemingly
uncontroversial seemingly a seemingly
uncontroversial pedigree and say well
tough luck you're stuck in Haiti right
subi and why because you don't have a
piece of paper from the government so I
mean am I going to get mad bill that you
can't go and cut hair without a license
but look
at the way the US government treats
would-be Haitian and migrants and say
that's fine it's it is a great and
bizarre feat of moral blindness and your
case for the most part rests on the
argument for increasing legal
immigration although you do address the
various iterations of illegal
immigration over the years because I do
think that's the other place where
sometimes you get libertarian
disagreement is okay maybe more
migration would be good maybe it would
be good for people be good for the
country but what about the rule of law
right and you know for that for that
what I say is when someone says I'm
against illegal immigration sometimes I
am totally Institue because I think it
should be legal right now I have found
that is a totally unpersuasive argument
because most people who are worried
about illegal immigration it's not just
the fact that it's illegal that bothers
them they think the law serves a good
purpose something I don't think I
actually talked about that much in the
book but I have blogged on it is when
exactly is it that a law is sufficiently
bad that it's okay to break it all right
now there's a knee-jerk reaction of you
should never break the law no matter
what's and I think sometimes even your
rule of law libertarians will say this
and then for them I'll say okay so you
always try the speed limit every single
time you never go mile over the speed
limit and then it's like so alright fine
idea right well are you doing something
evil right and for this it's like well
here's the thing it would be kind of
inconvenient to drive the speed limit so
it's okay to break the law it's like
well it's okay to break the law for just
a matter of inconvenience then how about
if the law is trapping you and your
children and dire poverty when all you
want to do is move to Miami and shine
shoes is it okay to break that law right
and you know to my minds you know the
the case for breaking immigration laws
is much stronger than the case for
speeding speeding laws actually serve
some very plausible social function
right and the harm that you could do to
someone from driving too fast it really
is a very serious one and it's a small
cost to you so that was the kind of
thing that maybe libertarians should
Bend on but for this when you're saying
look you have no right to live anywhere
in the first world no right to do any
job in the first world tough lock you're
born in Haiti too bad suck it up that's
the kind of law where for libertarians
to stand up for that seem
very odd to me so in addition to sort of
answering these libertarian arguments
you also I think like one page each just
bang through the basic ethic and ethical
and moral systems available so you do
utilitarian argument you do a Content
argument you kind of hit all of those
and then there's a moment in this book
where after you have devastatingly
established the case for open borders
you say okay but we might not get open
borders so now let's talk about what
else we can do and you call them keyhole
solutions right why do you call them
that I'm actually borrowing this from
economic journalist Tim Harford and so
he notes that it's standard in modern
surgery to try to not do a lot of extra
damage to the patient while you are
helping them so old-school civil war
surgery just involves hacking off body
parts and hoping that you don't get more
gangrene but modern surgery you'll
usually try to do the smallest incision
you can to address the very specific
problem so you don't wind up causing
further harm in the process of fixing
whatever was bothering in the first
place and Tim Harford said so similarly
for a lot of different policies that we
have we can usually think of a cheaper
more humane way of dealing with the
problem so you know there's things like
what to do about air pollution you could
go and write a phone books worth of
regulation or you could go and say
there's a tax on pollution and you can
do as much as you want but you have to
pay for it which then gives people
incentives to always be looking for
better and cheaper ways to reduce
pollution and gives incentives for
innovation to figure out better ways of
doing it so that you can then sell this
products so it's much better in terms of
cleaning up things at a low cost
right and then similarly for immigration
borrowing Tim's idea I said why don't we
go and listen complaints and try to
figure out cheaper more humane ways of
addressing the concerns again things
like Milton Friedman's story you can't
have unrestricted immigration and a
welfare state all right great let's just
take that for granted and say how about
we go and let immigrants in but we give
them reduced access to benefits for a
while which by the way we already do
some extent so it's not like a science
fiction idea rather it's one that was
already on the books and we just turn up
the dial to a higher level until people
finally calm down so I talked
about this for many other concerns
people have but again each case the idea
is first listen to the complaint what
exactly is it the same about immigrants
that's bothering you and then second is
there anything any way of addressing
this problem other than saying kick him
out and keep him out right and this is
actually something that I was struck by
in that last section it seems like you
spent much more time reassuring readers
or reminding them that the status quo
was already morally worse or that we
were already doing the thing that you
might intuitively see as morally
objectionable in these various solutions
I mean I found even as I was reading you
said okay sure let's let people in but
give them you know fewer access to
social services let's only let some
subset of people in from a region or you
know a culture and I had but I imagine
isn't very common intuitive reaction of
like well wait that's not fair and both
before and after each argument you sort
of said we're already doing this we're
already doing this my thing is still
better why did you feel like that
section of the book needed those
reassurances when the much more radical
arguments earlier in the book didn't or
you didn't do it as much right so in the
first five chapters of the book I'm
trying to convince people of what I
think in the next chapter I'm trying to
bargain with people that I have failed
to convince that's really what's going
on right and you know I'm an economist
and I'm a parent so I'm used to the idea
of bargaining with people and trying to
say all right what exactly is it that is
keeping us from getting your signature
on the page and so that's what I'm
really trying to do in that chapter
let's close we're talking about the
dedications to the book which I thought
were very striking um tell me about
yours and then if you can tell me a
little bit about tax mom my wife got out
of communist Romania when she was six
years old and then was stuck in Italy
for another six months while the US
government tried to figure out whether
she and her dad were spies right and so
yeah so you like your family well it was
a classic immigration story they came to
this country with nothing
her dad especially he had been a Alecto
manager and electrical plant when he was
back in Romania and then at the US he's
43 and has to learn a new language and
be a janitor right and he did all this
so that his daughter could have a better
life and so I dedicated the book to my
wife and her family for being part of
the
country story and just for being an
example of the kind of people that so
many people say should not be allowed
here because they're not good enough for
us and only why do you think they're not
good enough what exactly is it about
them that is so horrible that you don't
want them breathing the same air as as
we do and then for a Zak
so my co-author had family in Poland and
the former Soviet Union and some of them
got out before the US immigration laws
made that almost impossible and he is
descended from that branch of the family
and then the rest stayed and as far as
you can tell they all got murdered by
either the Nazis or the Communists and
so he actually put out a request if
anyone knows of any surviving relatives
of mine who might have made it out or
somehow kept their head down if you
could just let me know have you gotten
anything back about that I don't think
that he has unfortunately but maybe some
viewer at reason will know where the
long-lost branches the Weiner stiff of
the Wiener Smith family have ended up so
final question do you think that you
will live to see open borders or
anything that closely approximates it
hmm let's see how old am I again no so
yeah seems highly unlikely so a big part
of my work is distinguishing between
what should happen and what I actually
think will happen so I mean honestly I'm
just one person I think this is a book
that is very persuasive as far as books
go but the most persuasive book in the
world just isn't that persuasive to most
people unfortunately I wish I could do
better if someone else knows how to be
more persuasive that would be really
good this is my best shot I think it's
the kind of thing where you've got to
win people over very gradually you got
to focus on the young because older
people have generally just locked down
and made up their mind and actually I do
all say I feel better about the fact
this is the only book I've ever seen
where my little kids reading over my
shoulder so this is a book actually
while it isn't written for adults and
yet people who are much younger I'd say
a precocious 7 year olds could read the
book with profit so of course I have
dreams and fantasies about a whole
nation of children read this book and so
then within 25 years they've won things
over and we do get this my honest answer
is I think open borders will happen
eventually but unfortunately happen
after
so rich that most the games are no
longer there and on that pessimistic
optimistic note thank you very much
Brian Catherine thank you very much
always a great pleasure